chief character comes out behind him
holding his gun and they look at each
other and you're like good work boys
I'll screen their look and they look off
screen and Lara Croft comes and goes up
to this treasure chest it opens it up
what this inside is three Mario
power-ups they're going this way
violence behind them and she came this
side can we be on this side let's go in
she'll just do some side shot you can
get kind of steady in the camera sweeps
passing this returning looking to party
you know he lands behind them like that
start standing up and then cut into
maybe you know slow-mo slow-mo kind of
been shot shot shot shot reverse but
blah blah um and then pop down camera
you know whatever
grab grab thanks max I'm back as Connor
I think I'm fighting Mario but I think
he's in my butt today
hey I'm replaying Lara Croft whoo Tomb
Raider this is Laura Croft in a peacoat
you know traditionally I play leather
man which is just this full leather suit
with a mask that makes my beard pop out
but today you know I get to come out of
my shell a little bit play Master Chief
which is you know always an honor I've
always admired others of the suited kind
trivia was the which video wasn't where
the moustache wasn't correct do you
remember friends it was great video that
says Redskins yeah I upside down it
wasn't the mustache was upsetting yeah I
was upside down upside down mustache
that's how I differentiated between
which Mario I was playing it's a
different universe it's basically this
215 ax as usual although I got the 24 24
it will be good for certain moment
our own LED panel to do it well I guess
it's none other than the Helio the
brightest LED panel ever made actually
it is like one of the brightest LED
panels that are made I've been wanting
to try this out for years basically
rather than using a reflector today I'm
use this bad boy for edge lights and
fills even though we're outside in
direct sunlight see how it goes I'm
excited to try it out
are you gonna show your blog whopper for
your beer I think I forgot what after
tuck it into the Hat we take I just ate
it we could tape it yeah we clear that
would hurt
super bad all right that looks great
mm-hmm my good side panel
what I like the dirtier you get like the
more I own powering it is no bad as you
feel to worry about getting dirty
yeah exactly my right there I don't care
why I do that
why isn't Mario part of the original
squad I think so Mario's man at the
original squad in the first place cuz
he's not a member of the team they left
him out he's like the last kid picked in
kickball no I don't know if it's a
racial thing or a social economic thing
it's probably because their plumber
negation my family's plumbers just look
down on us or crops like a fancy glitch
running running she's not a nice person
and three two one action and three two
one action
Benji are you ready for the plane of
everyone's existence in the entire world
that's beer gum yes it that you have to
put on your face this beer gun you got
to remove her stuff right oh yeah three
after it's that cool
yes yeah dumb objective yes yes yeah
Halloween I'd to put this stuff on and
let me just tell you it's really hard
when you already have facial hair oh it
is pretty gross it's not to worry about
that facial hair about this guy never
grown one here my face my wife nope
can't do it with chest hairs even more
better on my neck or the chest hairs
straighten Barris is you I am too I hit
you chest hair alright alright we're
just going to be careful that for a
second you mind just yeah doing a three
finger press do you feel like you have
enough fluid there to keep it sticky
we'll see is press little job your
finger press Sam
damn this mustache is a little turkey
your little crooked no I'm serious
like a cop no not like a crooked cop
it's just crooked like a judge let me
see what it looks like on camera
what's great you guys will start running
okay I'll say stop that means that that
means you come come to a full halt after
slowing and looking and then land which
is kind of just like this is kind of
like just just kind of like react to
that small impact of him hitting the
ground we can um so we're running this
is what he's like landing with it's like
almost like with a shock wave
essentially while you decide to remove
him rather than just Adam in on a green
screen looks better
he's more timely on screen he does
off-screen dr. Kayson yeah that's that
yeah that's that's what it comes down to
yeah he's he's in the shot more also
like when he lands the whole plate the
whole clean plate we get to easily
digitally remove that by putting a giant
explosion in its place you know so it's
easy to just like blip out that little
clean play play be a little evil here
okay just kind of maybe intimidating a
little air cameras rolling and three two
one action
give a nice big green at the end there
how do you make him scary no magnets
they don't make him scary like yelling
do GUI
hey it's me hey it's me that one I
didn't know much subtlety in it it's me
after it's pizza it's me it's it it's me
sorry it's me
it's a me yeah it's me make it a
question it's me uh what it's me it's me
and action
it's a me
it's me
that's perfect perfect that was one of
my favorite ones either can't anything
get less better than that three two one
action
crap what are you doing is illegal dude
you're you're illegally filming me in
front of police officers back I really
gonna take it you want to get a good tee
shot so yeah I'm just like what are you
guys doing I'm like shooting a music
video I like because usually they're
like oh you're shooting YouTube video
whatever but this time because in LA
they're like that but here they're more
I guess they're just more in strict
about it make much money off of parking
tickets the location down the street
with no reason for us not being here
then they say it's private well my
programs and Robert ESI they give them a
heart about Karma well let's just go to
a minecraft area forever yeah probably
my area along the tracks and the side of
that the side of that warehouse shutting
it down
can't see anything in there from the
road we have running running and
stopping the Mario close-ups are fine we
can kind of keep those the case closed
up spine and keep that we have four
shots three do it's not big deal so
let's just pack up and go the other spot
literally if we pay for permits in the
city of La and burn we would never make
money and we would never be able to do
this that's how stringent Department is
ours
is they're tailored and they're written
for the major studios and the major
production companies I can actually
afford it if you're trying to make
videos on your own you lose all of your
money in fees if you do that so you're
put in a situation like this but that's
okay
you just deal with it look okay pop
right now okay let me that's good so
it's a it's like it's yes right before
this guy starts fighting him
Oh gotcha so I'm it's like fun yeah yeah
pretty much sweet good great awesome
all right question all right answer I've
ever played tomato before are you trying
to make me like a fool yes I'm um no but
I'm familiar with the character oh okay
yeah uh what is it what did she do in
the game ah um I'm gonna say I think she
reads tunes it's it's basically correct
perfect today we're using a new
microphone now that we got to see k-tec
Nautilus shotgun amount it's really cool
I've never seen anything like it it the
loop that hold the shotgun that holds
microphone spins all the way around the
spiral and holds it right there just
like free-floating without any rubber
bands or anything it's pretty sweet
yeah there you go
good dude seriously just that turn
around pick up old ones was this that's
good this is Whitehead I was going to
turn around don't hurt yourself come do
my foot hurts so bad right now let's go
back because you stepped on it sideways
like it out and let it pull gun it Benji
there's like I can't even touch it on
the outside right there's like there's
like a crack in the foot I think oh dude
your hope what's correct like my foot
again you can feel it like this like it
a dent in it I can't like put anyway
love it did you agree I think something
as I heard it pop I heard a pop and I
felt a pop that I didn't want to land us
it hurt dude it's bad it was really bad
but like I want to get this done so like
literary right right right
all right let's see it looks like
there's a ridge there that's usually not
there darling right there dude that's
never there that bump that's all the
pain is - yeah I just stepped on the
side
I think vinci focus but you think we got
that insurance obamacare it's a gay can
swing the foot around here just swinging
the wood around right-footed - I know
dude don't get your left you don't
actually have to kick in I can't put
weight on it and it's just going on oh
we're gonna get baked this in the two
shots for you okay all right let's do
this Benji your star star power that's
up all right cameras rolling and three
two one action
nice to one action
nice that's really good maybe yelled it
no quit my parents are gonna yell at me
or okay he's gonna yell at me yeah she's
gonna yell me I worst I'm sorry you're
done
no let's do it right nobody could say X
it was it is good go cuz it you even
though it's an hour I just tell me like
if it's bad like I'll keep going til you
you want your you did a good job to what
I get it correct don't let mom and dad
see this so today I wanted really fast
Lynn swapping so I took my airsoft dump
bag in another dump big we put them all
my belt
and I just got a bunch of lenses in them
doesn't matter that we ended up you
can't your head your arms in the way and
you'll probably posit yeah I got it
Stutzman
got hide your face that's like how
freaking sweet is it fifty per and
literally does a baffle through the
frame like I feel like it's way cool
even though it's a little more roto work
it's cooler when stepping yeah okay just
keep in second at the joke and every
wrong door really cool though it looks
better it looks better
will speed rampant or something it's all
say one of the dogs chewed on this and
now it's impossible to get a clean piece
of tape off of it thanks Rocky
whatever sure beer sir oh alright that's
the girl
how much fun is it making this music uh
where's my mind because if you look at
this like it gives me a headache
listening to it because I have to just
listen to it repeated over and over and
over and over and over again so I've
heard this probably about a hundred
times that we're going kind of crazy
I in this piece they have Master Chief
throw a giant-sized and rather than
having to shoot him on a green screen
and you a whole bunch of compositing
actually it's enforced perspective which
is a classic trick it a lot of Disney
movies back in like the 1950s so
basically add Master Chief from really
close to the camera we have Benjy as
Mario but really far away from the
camera and we kind of line them up so we
didn't teach something we'll look at so
it looks like they're looking at each
other and so in that side shot or Master
Chief runs up to Mario and Mario's
looking up at him
there's no compositing that shot Master
Chief is actually just close to the
camera and Mario is just far away and
you know add some smoke and some of that
kind of stuff and deal over to speed
changing on the people to make them seem
bigger or smaller but other than that no
compositing needed it's all just one
shot just tricking your eyes a
two-dimensional picture hobbit stop it's
time for the Piranha plant eating lower
crop shot I wanted to try to do some
really crazy specials it's the last
effect shot in the whole piece I saw
that with a spline which is basically
just a line in three dimensions 3dsmax
can have that line to form things so I
made a stock or stem so animated that
made it wiggle out like snake and flip
left and right and then go back into the
hole but then to make it really special
I need to make physically simulative
leaves that would flop and fly like real
beads I did a simulation for each and
every leaf on the plant so as the stock
waved around the leaves where I'll
physically assimilated to them and wave
around beneath it so start making things
look really realistic and really cool
and kind of made up for my somewhat
hacky animation skills then I took I've
spear cut it a little bit to living
pac-man and brought that into Mudbox or
I could then my kind of a sculpted like
clay and I made the head painted it real
quick made it red with white lips and
the muldiss white spots me head I had to
make it look extra cool and to do that I
used fume effects and cranked the
gravity so the smoke from fume effects
would fall like sands because it shoots
out the hole the smoke is rolling out
the leaves and looks like sand and dirt
falling out the plant and final steps to
put lower crop in the mouth so I took a
3d model of Laura prop from the most
recent game which I found on
that rigged it attached it to the plants
mouth and then and rate the legs flop
around as the plants head flopped around
and through and some teeth to make it
extra deadly looking put it all together
in after-effects and that's how I did
that shot and it was so cool that I just
took the plant element slowed it down
and reuse it in some other shots when
you have that the wide shots kind of set
it up also when it comes up and snatches
her from the close-up we just recorded
her going like that and then I just
recorded or just rendered out the
beginning of my animation from a
different angle that lined up and then
it all actually worked out and look
really sweet I work from Wednesday
Thursday Friday and then part of
Saturday and part of Sunday just
finished that last shot meanwhile Sam
finished like 20 effect shots
my last effects are now and the color
instincts can go on the internet you
guys see dude I need to give us a bell